hi guys i'm matt i'm a tasty producer
and i love chicken wings i think they're
one of the most perfect versatile foods
out there you can enjoy them savory
sweet spicy baked grilled the
possibilities are endless which is why i
think that no matter how much time you
have you should be able to enjoy the
ultimate chicken wing so today i'll be
sharing three recipes for a 10 minute a
one hour and a one day chicken wing
let's get started say you're feeling
lazy maybe you've had a long day of work
or you just don't want a mess to clean
up these 10 minute wings are the recipe
for you to get started i'm adding a
little bit of oil to a pan over medium
heat now that my oil is at temperature
i'm just going to add my wings to the
pan the reason i'm going with these
pre-cooked ones is it'll take less time
because we only have to bring them up to
temperature rather than cooking them all
the way through these are going to cook
for about a minute or two until they're
browned and then we're going to flip
them and repeat on the other side and
some nice browning on the underside look
at that so it's time to make our sauce
i'm adding some soy sauce and then i'm
adding a special ingredient this is cola
now you can use any soda you want as
long as it's not a sugar-free variety
you need that sugar so it cooks down and
thickens nicely i'm going to turn the
heat up to high so this comes to a boil
i'm just going to let this cook until
it's nice and thickened and forms a
little glaze on the top of my chicken
and as you can see my soy sauce and cola
mixture has reduced nicely it's a thick
sauce it's glazing all of my chicken
this looks delectable pop them onto a
plate oh wow
so saucy
get a little bit of that sauce drizzle
that over the top no good bits go to
waste and then to finish just some nice
scallions on the top add a pop of color
add a bit of freshness and there you
have it 10 minute cola wings these look
awesome let's give it a shot let's see
how we did oh nice and sticky
oh wow these are shockingly good for
only taking 10 minutes to make the cola
adds a nice glaze and sweetness to the
outside the chicken itself is perfectly
tender if you want to make wings in a
pinch this is the recipe for you however
if you want something a bit more
impressive stick around for our one hour
wings we couldn't make a video about
chicken wings without including the
all-time classic buffalo wings these are
great for a game night they're great if
you're having friends over and honestly
they're pretty good if you're having
them by yourself because guess what
these are baked so technically that
means they're healthier my wings are all
padded dry so now it's time to season
them generously sprinkle them with some
salt and a bit of pepper toss these
until they're nice and evenly coated i'm
going to set my wings aside and now it's
time to get started on the dry rub for
my wings so in a bowl i'm combining
baking powder and we're actually using
aluminum free baking powder we recommend
it just in case someone is sensitive to
the metallic taste garlic powder onion
powder finally a little bit of smoked
paprika and just stir all of it together
until evenly combined bring back my
wings and i'm just sprinkling my dry rub
all over the top and then toss until
everything is nice and evenly coated oh
this smells so good and i have here a
greased rack to which i'm going to add
my wings and i'm just placing them face
up on the rack and the baking powder
that's in the rub for these wings is
really going to help them dry out and
develop a crispiness on the outside very
similar to if you were to fry them in
oil but sands the oil and then of course
the reason we are baking these on a rack
is that our air circulates evenly which
is going to help our wings crisp up even
more pop these in a 425 degree oven for
about 30 to 45 minutes 30 if your wings
are on the smaller side 45 if your wings
are on the thicker side they'll take a
little bit longer to cook while the
wings are baking in the oven it is the
perfect time to make homemade ranch
dressing now you can totally go and buy
ranch dressing from the store if you
want to but we have the time to make it
and it's a great way of just leveling up
your entire meal in a large bowl i'm
combining sour cream mayonnaise
buttermilk add a little bit of tang to
it apple cider vinegar garlic powder
onion powder fresh dill and finally some
salt just whisk all that together and
that's really it that's how you make
homemade ranch dressing it's really that
easy i'm just going to pop this in the
refrigerator until my wings are ready
and move on to the next step we still
have plenty of downtime so why not make
buffalo sauce from scratch it's super
easy and you can customize it basically
any way you want to get started i have a
pan over medium heat to which i am
adding some butter and as the butter is
melting i'm going to add my hot sauce
and what's great about this is you can
use literally whatever hot sauce you
like if you have a specific preference
or brand or whatever go for it i'm
adding some honey just to round things
out to kind of take the edge off the
acidity a little bit of worcestershire
sauce some garlic powder and finally i'm
just adding a little bit of cayenne
pepper to the top add as much as you
prefer if you want it hotter go with a
little bit more if you want it on the
mild side add a little bit or none and
just whisk all of that together until
nice and combined make sure your butter
is emulsified i'm bringing this to a
boil and letting it go for about three
to four minutes until thickened once
your buffalo sauce comes to a boil kick
the heat down to about medium high and
continue to stir until it's thickened
and saucy that's all it takes to make
buffalo sauce we're just going to set
this aside and grab our chicken wings
now it is time to bring all of our
elements together to a bowl i'm adding
my wings and you can hear how crisp they
are as they go in and then just pour
your buffalo sauce all over the top and
then toss until all of the wings are
coated in that luscious spicy
buttery buffalo sauce oh my goodness in
the words of my idol emerald lagasse i
wish you had smell-o-vision oh my god
these look so good i am so excited i'm
personally huge fans of the flats but
comment below if you prefer flats or
drums and there we are that is one hour
baked buffalo wings with homemade
buffalo sauce and ranch dressing let's
try our one hour buffalo chicken wings
get a little bit of that ranch on there
here we go
oh hell yeah
oh my god
if someone put a plate of these out at a
party i would absolutely crush this
they're crunchy on the outside the
buffalo is not too spicy but adds a good
bit of heat to it the ranch is super
creamy and tart this is a phenomenal
recipe and if you have an hour to spare
absolutely try this try every part of it
i can't recommend it enough now if you
have a little bit more time and some
patience this last recipe is really
gonna blow your socks off our final
recipe today is a one day sweet and
spicy sticky wing now this is a
three-step process we're gonna start
with a dry brine for flavor we're then
going to clean feed them so they get
wonderfully tender on the inside and
we're going to close things out with a
deep fry so they form a beautiful
crispiness on the outside and with that
being said let's get started so first
things first we need to make our dry
brine in a bowl i'm adding salt sugar
and then finally gochugaru which is a
korean chili pepper flake and just mix
all of that until combined and the goji
garu adds some nice red color to that
and just add your dry brine over the top
of your wings once they're nicely coated
just toss everything until combined and
the reason we're doing a dry brine is
that's really going to allow our flavors
to penetrate the meat all the way
through it's also going to help
tenderize our meat as well and once the
wings are nice and coated place them on
a baking sheet face up much like we did
for the buffalo wings pop the wings in
the fridge uncovered for about four
hours or even overnight just to let
those flavors really really penetrate
when your wings come out of the fridge
they should glisten you should see all
the moisture kind of collected on the
surface now we're ready to confit them
config is where you cook something in
its own fat or in an oil this is a great
way of ensuring it's super super tender
it also keeps things moist
to start just transfer your chicken to a
baking dish perfect it's like a puzzle
look at that and then to the chicken
just add some ginger garlic
and finally our scallions and as this
cooks these are just going to impart
more flavor on our chicken at this point
it is time to add our fat or in this
case olive oil just pour this over your
chicken until each piece is completely
covered
this is very pretty you've got your reds
your greens it's almost like christmas
colored
there we are at this point you're ready
to pop this in a 300 degree oven for
about two and a half to three hours also
a good pro tip when you pop this in the
oven put it over a baking sheet that way
any drippings or if anything bubbles
over will be caught and won't burn in
your oven i'll see you guys in three
hours so after a couple of hours it's
starting to pull away from the bone at
the edges but it's not completely
falling apart just transfer it to a foil
lined baking sheet i feel like at every
single stage of this recipe it's just
looked really pretty the colors always
look super nice and here is our last
piece now you can totally discard this
oil if you want to you can also save it
and confit again just pop it in the
freezer and it should keep for a few
months pop the chicken in the fridge for
about an hour this is going to help it
cool down it's also going to help it
stay together when we fry it as the
chicken is cooling off in the fridge it
is time to make our sauce now this sauce
comes from alvin's fried chicken recipe
link in the description if you want to
check that out to a pan we are adding
rice vinegar
soy sauce honey
minced garlic ginger and then finally
gochujang and gochujang is a korean
chili paste if you've never tried
gojujeng before you are missing out
we're just going to stir this all
together until combined let the sauce
start to bubble and then go for another
three to four minutes you want it to
thicken up form a nice sticky luscious
sauce that we're gonna use to coat our
chicken i think it's ready to go so
we're going to set this aside and then
move on to frying our chicken we are in
the final stretch before i do anything i
need to prep my batter in a bowl i have
cornstarch to which i'm going to add
flour salt and finally water give that a
good whisk we want it to be
smooth no lumps stick the cornstarch on
the bottom there there we go look at
that beautiful and that is our batter
now it's time to coat our wings in a
separate bowl here i have cornstarch i'm
just going to pop my wings inside and
use the same hand to coat them i'm going
to shake off the excess drop it into my
batter and just using my tongs i'm going
to toss all of my chicken in my batter
make sure everything is coated trying to
be gentle i don't want to like tear my
chicken or break any of that super
tender meat and then at this point it's
time to fry so i'm just going to shake
off that excess batter and then i'm
going to add it to my oil oh i love
frying chicken it's so relaxing it's so
soothing and i'm going to make sure
nobody's sticking together my oil is
heated to 350 degrees these are gonna
cook for about four to five minutes
until they're golden brown and crispy on
the outside my wings are looking good
pull them from the oil beautiful and
there we are
ah
you can hear
how crisp it is it's time to drizzle
over that gorgeous sauce we made
yes
finally toss everyone to coat which is
honestly a little bit hard because they
are so crunchy wow you can really hear
how crispy these are oh my goodness look
at them this is like the best of
everything it's shiny it's sticky it's
crunchy it's tender and i'm just gonna
top with a little bit of that extra
sauce to finish this top with some
toasted sesame seeds a little bit of
cilantro and finally some thinly sliced
scallions and there you go there you
have it one day sweet and spicy sticky
wings i'm very excited to try these who
do i want to pick first
you
[Music]
i don't know if i've ever eaten a piece
of chicken that was that crunchy oh my
god this is hands down probably the
crunchiest piece of chicken i have ever
had in my life holy cow it's super flaky
and delicate on the inside the meat is
really really tender the sauce works
really really well too it's sticky but
it has a little bit of heat from the
gochujang it's a little bit sweet if you
have a full day and you want to do
something and you want to commit to
making these wings i say go for it if
you don't call out of work make these
and have a grand old time these are
awesome these are really really good
wings if you're in a pinch we have 10
minute easy cola wings if you've got a
little bit more time or are hungry on a
weeknight we have the one hour buffalo
wings with homemade ranch dressing and
homemade buffalo sauce or if you want to
pull out all the stops go the extra mile
we have the one day sweet and spicy
sticky wings let me know which recipe is
your favorite in the comments below or
message me on instagram take care and
i'll see you guys next time when you
have some time to cook
oh yes
[Music]
you